quiere asegurarse que tiene
efectivamente esos apoyos en el bolsillo
por ello ha iniciado hoy una ofensiva
política no solamente con los partidos
sino con los empresarios de Irlanda del
Norte que han sido bien afectados desde
el brexit que este el acuerdo Wilson es
el mejor posible tras la salida del
Reino Unido de la Unión Europea hace
tres años necesita especialmente el
apoyo de los unionistas de Irlanda del
Norte que como lo mencionabas están hace
bastante tiempo más de un año evitando
que se cumplan los acuerdos y haya
entonces una negociación para tener un
ejecutivo con los republicanos del
chinfein Así que la idea especialmente
es eso lograr que se resuelva el camino
político entre tanto el Primer Ministro
sunat en reunión con empresarios ha
dicho entre otras que este acuerdo
Windsor es extremadamente bueno dijo
además que el protocolo estaba rompiendo
con el equilibrio entre las comunidades
ha dicho y calificado de ridículos los
trámites que tiene que hacer por ejemplo
una familia en Londres para poder enviar
un regalo de cumpleaños a belfast el
mismo país en Irlanda del Norte por la
cantidad de trámites inspecciones y
burocracia a la que he sometido bien
importante dice que se acabará el
desabastecimiento de alimentos frescos
que ha sido una de las constantes desde
que se firmó el brexit hace tres años
también ha dicho que la asamblea de
Irlanda del norte de stormont que se
espera haceforme el gobierno rápidamente
propondrá bloquear cualquier ley nueva
que afecte a las comunidades entre tanto
el D up ha dicho que está analizando
minuciosamente palabra por palabra los
documentos de El acuerdo Windsor para
emitir un concepto final sobre si apoya
o no al gobierno pero una buena noticia
para Richie sunak y con la que puede
respirar por lo menos un poco es que los
eurocéticos de su partido del partido
conservador en el parlamento parece que
se están subiendo al bus del acuerdo
Windsor Y entonces sería una realidad en
el parlamento británico